Sức hiện vinh nước sạch cả chăm mát trên một quà đối tạng lihanh. Theo bỏ tiền phòng, người dân thất hiện,
quà đối ở bàn sốc phen, sạm mửi tiếp, phân kuyen, có vết nước lớn trả ngàn cả quà đối,
vết nước kéo sạch cả chăm mát, có điều, vết nước sộng hình bười sẻ tinh mát và có giấu hiệu suốt,
sát lửa thêm. Vết nước còn trả ngàn qua để nhạc của có thủ dân. Nhận được thông tin,
các quán chức năng vệ ký sơn, công ngân vệ ký sơn đã lập tức để điện trưởng để khảo sát và đâm bắt để gình.
Hẹn thay vết nước người hiệu và quà đối có thể đường sắp xuống mất cứ lúc nào,
nhưng các quán chức năng đã phối hợp với lực lượng lihanh phòng đâm trên địa bàn
cân chương dây dời năm bộ sân sức xuống vệ giữa đến đoạn.
Cán bộ chế sĩ đông lihanh phòng mửi ai, bộ chợh thảo sớm nhà của thác khổ sân
đưa đến đoạn tạm lihanh tạm lihanh chợ chế thạy ước mức thấp nhất.
Hẹn công tác lươi dây nhà, tay sọng của vệ sân đa ký thúc lực truyền khai,
đàn công tác khổ sân đến đoạn viên tất nhiêu yếu phòng bảo gộ gạo.
Mít ông nước ủng cho các khổ sân tục sĩ,
thái gì dời dời dời dời tình chạy luôn nữa.